there's so much I know about Lobster and
the funny thing I tell everybody is I
hate Seafood I won't eat it for me to
stare at lobsters for weeks is like the
dumbest thing in the world to me but you
know here we are and then you know we
have a line out front what's up GQ this
is Dion Point creative director for
Concepts and this is my life and
sneakers
[Music]
I grew up in Brockton Massachusetts a
very long time ago probably before any
Jordans around the shelves it was a
little bit of a rough and gritty
neighborhood I'd say so getting sneakers
wasn't necessarily the easiest course of
action for us so I probably got my first
sneaker when the sky Jordans came out
which was the 1985 edition of the Jordan
for a smaller feet which I still have
like a size nine right now that kind of
gave me the appetite for sneakers but
then I wouldn't get another Jordan
probably until the 11th so it was a
grueling path for sure trying to be a
sneakerhead back there it wasn't
necessarily the uh insatiable appetite
there is now so you could actually go in
and buy a shoe maybe not even just the
day of you had a couple weeks the Jordan
one in particular some decathlon Sports
I think had them for as low as twenty
dollars times are tougher back then I
don't think people had the uh the Deep
Pockets that they do now kids are
wearing like balenciagas to high school
that's that's wild to me
oddly enough I read about a life in a GQ
article and I was like what the hell is
this store it's a library what is it so
I booked it to New York and checked it
out and I was like an off but I didn't
know what concepts was at that point I
was still going to New York to get all
my sneakers we were doing 125th hitting
every store in New York because they had
a different offering wider I saw almost
things like that crazy 95s things like
that so I was going up there buying you
know everything I get my hands on and
then I found out about Concepts I found
out about Concepts at a baby shower some
kid had the acorns on and I was like wow
this is crazy where'd you get those of
course the the thing you say when you're
from Boston is I got them in New York
it's your way of basically brushing
people off like you're not getting what
I got so lo and behold my brother called
me he was like I saw the store that they
have the icons at it's in Cambridge I'm
in Cambridge Massachusetts like yeah
it's a Cambridge so we headed over there
and we were like what is this they had
year the Horse Air Forces biotech dunks
Bo Jackson's they just had this weird
assortment of shoes because they had a
higher tear to come and I was just blown
away and then from there is kind of
where you know nature took its course it
was like going to a thrift store you
know like it was exactly that feeling
because you walk through this Mom and
Pop store that had like Birkenstocks and
Minnetonka and all these shoe companies
that a lot of people aren't familiar
with and then you get in the back and
it's just rap music classes weeks of
like weed and incense and just like what
is this how did I find this and then I
never told anybody about it I kept it to
myself you know I fell in love with that
store I spent all my money I couldn't
make that trip up every week and there
was so much stuff coming out that I just
couldn't keep up so that's when I
offered to kind of come on like as a
part-time gigs I work on the weekends
sometimes I would come in my
construction clothes change in the back
and work on like a weekday but again I
wasn't doing it for the money I had
money I just was like I just needed to
get my access to these shoes but he was
letting me buy the shoes at cost so of
course you're going to buy four pairs of
something not that sure I didn't I
couldn't get four of those I wish but I
had three of them
for those that don't know this is the
Neapolitan
Cherry in the tongue it was no brainer
this is probably at a time when color
blocking was minimal so it made sense
our allocation was probably super light
we probably got 12 pairs of this for the
shop in playing fair this is before line
called just though too you know you're
seeing them show up in magazines from
Japan you're like what is that shoe no
clue it's even Stussy probably traded at
1.5 or 6 other sneakers to get one of
these and this was before the equity was
there so this wasn't a five thousand
dollar shoe probably a few hundred
dollars back then you know everybody
that wants to work in sneakers it's
always like you know I want to come in
design I want to do this but for us it
was always like you had to start in the
stockroom so we memorized skus I knew I
knew like my hard color codes and all
that stuff I just nerded out on it I
kind of like being back there better
than on the floor then um you know
natural progression get on the floor
that's when you stop meeting raps and
people from Brands and I think that's
how the first opportunity came about for
us to do a collab was
2007 with New Balance part of this uh
super team 33 structure that they have
like us a life body La there's a lot of
groups that came in to this day my
biggest mistake it was the worst shoe
I've ever worked on every time it pops
up on like someone's trying to give me
props I'm like please burn that shoe and
I'll give you a new one like I hate it
you live and you learn
[Music]
so this I think is our one of our
favorite New Balance that we have ever
did it's called the C note if you're a
real New Balance head you'll notice
there's something different about this
I'm not going to say anything more than
that we kind of did it with this dusted
toe box for a reason we knew that once
they kind of got worn in people would
probably want another pair and we kept
the market pairs low I want to say if we
did maybe like a thousand or something
of these for whatever reason like the
PRS they are constantly honing me to
like bring these back out and it's just
kind of like almost a grill for a lot of
kids that are into New Balance the New
Balance heads they need everything
structured the right way what Factory
it's made in I mean they're like
aficionados here I have not won yet
you know Virgil there's not enough good
things you could say about him but
there's just so many subtle little
details he puts in all his product he
just got the Midas touch it's not on
everything for me but especially with
the forces I think he realized that uh
sometimes less is more and I think this
is perfect and I and I honestly would
have never wore all baby blue sure in my
life even though it's one of my favorite
colors blue top to bottom is crazy and
it just works it makes sense this one
here the reason why I brought this
because it's actually we're full circle
we're in Miami right now my friend James
Whitner and Frank cook sent me these so
this is one of the shoes that's like
close to my heart I know they go for a
lot of money I wore the pink ones into
the ground that they sent me but they
launched these in Miami at Basel I want
to save my mask correct 2018 even though
it might look just like you know muted
colors kind of low-key this is
absolutely one of my favorite shoes I
just I need a special reason to rock
though so that's one that's not getting
one I'm a Jordan one junkie um that
stems from obviously the sky Jordan so I
keep as many pairs of these as I can the
originals the black and red in the black
and blue but um so these come along
they're just easier to get a little bit
pricey but they're still not as pricey
as having the OG so and I thought the
details are cool in the marketing last
but not least if I could reach this here
I don't think anybody's seen this
impression yet this is the white lobster
this is friends and family only so it
won't be for retail but I wanted to
share this with you guys because I
thought it was cool this is extremely
lazy I'm not gonna lie to anybody so the
reason why I picked this color for
friends and families because it's so
minimal pairs they found it albino
Lobster there's also one with these
crazy hairy claws that's like
prehistoric the story wasn't there for
me I couldn't do anything with it and I
was like if there's gonna be one shoe
that's limited that won't kill people
and not have them like white might be
the easiest to cope with
[Music]
you might have to correct me but I think
this seventh rendition of the lobster
series uh the first one came about you
know us trying to do something cool with
SB trying to pitch a a project to them
and they were at that time infernal hot
so they weren't really listening to
anything even though we're one of the
first accounts in the entire world if
not the first to carry USB it doesn't
mean like we just gotta streamline to
the president you know we had a few
ideas that kind of failed before that
that they weren't really Fallen away so
Lobster came about and then that's when
I kind of started working on the blue
officer immediately pitched that to them
they were like no we're not doing it
then I got the call like six months
after this drop the red one that we can
do the blue we survived the sophomore
jinx it was more so like what are you
gonna do after this I think it's a
little lazy for us to continuously do
this but the reality is the consumer
wants it we're all wearing Renditions of
the same sneaker anyway so what's the
difference here if you have an Air Force
or up time you got in 50 colors what's
the difference if I do eight colors of
this but for the real problem is how do
I sell it to you how do I how do I
Market it to you how do I tell you this
isn't the same story and that's where I
kind of started looking into Dolly and
all these things in the art world and
then how Lobster works and art if it's a
still life painting if it's this they
put me in this rabbit hole and I'm like
you know I don't come out for like weeks
and then I open the door to my office
and like I got it and that's when kind
of all this around you came about so
that's when it becomes fun for me again
because yeah this is this isn't really
fun for me to just pick colors and then
I have to Google like is there a real
orange Lobster they found one his name
is cheddar it's a real thing look it up
if anybody think of making it up but
yeah I'm pumped on this one I like it
and orange is one of my least favorite
colors for me personally I think I work
on all the the packaging the
storytelling the marketing plan almost
the same time as I'm submitting The
Shield because I have to have a
framework of How It's Gonna how it's
gonna come out I was gonna roll and I
was going to be different than the last
one so it's become a little bit of the
painstaking process the top of the next
one you know us going above and beyond
and creating this immersive experience
is just the evolution of Footwear right
because how do you keep the excitement
there if it's not just colors I think
it's cool for them to be able to explain
it to their friends and family too of
why they waited in line or why they went
to help for me being a Avid Storyteller
in my personal life it translates over
the product and I like to be able to you
know hopefully share that with the
consumer thank you guys for watching my
life and sneakers I hope to see you guys
again soon